hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of the final day of the finals of
the chess blue masters knockouts it's
ding leona versus pragananda and this is
game six of their second match so if
you've um i've been following what's
going on uh yesterday ding defeated
pragernanda
and now prague needs to bounce back in
order to force thai breaks and as this
is game six that means that he has uh
been able to force tie breaks uh the
first game ended in a draw second game
prague was able to win a very very tough
end game third game was the craziest
game i believe of the entire match of
both matches so i'm going to cover that
one i just uh decided to just summarize
everything in one video today and then
tomorrow we're really gonna do a nice
one for for that game uh game four ended
in a draw which means that pragananda
won the second match so he uh definitely
bounced back and now we have the blitz
tie breaks uh this is the second game
first game ended in the draw uh this is
the final one uh if
nothing happens then we go into
armageddon but uh well maybe something
happened so here ding has the white
pieces let's see what happened uh he
opens with d4 we have knight to f6 by
prague with c for e6 knight to c3 and
bishop to b4 he goes for the nimzo
indian defense we have e3 and prague
castles bishop to d2 we have c5 striking
in the center uh sorry not c5 d5
striking in the center
and a3 challenging the bishop on b4
bishop goes back to e7 uh and now knight
to f3 so again nothing new this has all
been played before we have b6 preparing
to fee and get to the light square
bishop c captures dingoes for uh
pontraid in the center of captures and
rook to c1 we have c5 now striking in
the center uh and d captures on c5 we
have b captures and now bishop to d3 so
it's not all that impressive for white
black definitely got all the counter
play
that black could get uh you know playing
a a a a super grand master like ding and
now it's time to just continue playing
well and here bishop to b7 is a known
move however prague goes for bishop to
g4 it's a new move so already as of
movie 11 we have a completely new game
uh ding challenges the bishop uh bishop
back to h5 and now knight to e2 and this
is where things get really interesting
it's uh it's a very interesting there to
give
uh prague who who bounced back in the in
the second day and now uh if he wins the
game uh he wins the entire match he wins
the adjustable masters uh and uh do do
capture on f3 uh this means that of
course you mess up white's uh pawn
structure in front of the king but also
uh after captures and captures at some
point sorry captures and captures at
some point white will get the semi-open
g file for the attack so prague decides
that it is worth it and it is the in
fact the strongest move recommended by
the engine he goes for a bishop captures
on f3 g captures and now knight b to d7
are continuing development you still
have to get both rooks into the game
bishop to c3 of course now ding assumes
this diagonal with the bishop um
at some point like we said the rook will
will come to g1
rook to e8 and now interestingly not
going for rook to g1 but first ding
castles he wants to put the king on h1
or h2 and then uh
hopefully double up rooks on the g file
knight to f8 the prague will put of
course the knight on the g6 square that
to block any uh incoming fire from the g
file and now knight the g3 now
interestingly uh this knight to f8 move
isn't all that great because bishop to
b5 just wins the pawn of course it's a
bliss game so uh moves like these will
be missed but uh how do you defend here
your rook is hanging if you defend with
this knight then you're no longer
defending the d5 pawn and then can just
win a pawn and if you defend with this
knight then we eliminated this knight
and after bishop captures because the
knight is again pinned we just captured
the pawn on d5 that's um that's the good
stuff and uh of course the knight is
hanging so you don't have time to play
bishop captures on b2 uh but okay it's a
blitz game knights to g3 was played we
have knights to g6 and now knight to f5
and excellent square for the knight uh
but the prague will not impressed just
bishop to f8 the bishop will be an
excellent defender here and the rook and
queen are doing a good job on the dnd
file so bishop back to b1 at some point
the queen might uh assume also this
diagonal so you could put a lot of
pressure here uh but just d4 link says
you uh progress says you've got nothing
here uh let's strike in the center e
captures on d4 and not knight to d5
going for uh uh going for a checkmating
attack uh the queen is coming to g5 with
check the knight is coming to f4 this
knight might come to h4 so basically you
just want to checkmate the white king uh
ding says all right let's see what you
got uh d captures on c5 now creating a
past c pawn queen to g5 would check kink
the h2 and now rook 8 d8 if you go for
this knight to f4 right away then rogue
g1 we stop checkmate and we get uh
all the control play that we need and we
have immense pressure on this g7 square
so instead after king h2 uh progress
says okay let's continue development
rook 8 28 the queen is still on d1 queen
to a4 excellent developing move by ding
now the queen can be shifted over to g
for to help out with the defense but
prague doesn't allow it knight to d to
f4 preventing queen to g4 and that's
just a lot of pieces in front of ding's
king so rook the g1 has to be played the
checkmate is being threatened so rook to
g1 and now queen to h5 getting the queen
out of harm's way again threatening
checkmate with queen captures on h3 but
also the f3 pawn is hanging so rogue g3
we defend everything and not knight to
e2 probably goes after the rook and now
you can't really move this rook if you
move the rook the other knight comes to
f4 and that's it there's no defending
this position so here dean just plays
rook c the g1 he offers a a rook but he
has to do it in order to uh
to defend this position and now prague
has to decide whether to go for the rook
or maybe he wants to capture the bishop
because this bishop is also a monster
maybe capture the bishop and then grab
the c5 pawn uh also uh has some merit to
it but okay knight captures on g3 prague
goes for the rook instead rook captures
on g3 and now rook to e2 going after the
f2 pawn this will come with check so
bishop the d for defending and now how
do you continue this it's uh it's an
insane position to have in a blitz game
uh i mean
it's a beautiful position but crazy a
complete madness here
and probably goes for rook to d2 he puts
uh pressure more pressure on the d file
uh there was the very interesting knight
to h4 i'm just going to show it even
though it's a blitz game you guys will
love this line it's uh it's just
beautiful it's basically a
a big sausage of a force to draw uh
basically what you what you now want to
do is you are threatening the f3 pawn so
here we're just going to play but also
you are allowing white to capture on g7
so that's the the idea behind it so
knight captures on g7 bishop captures on
g7 rook captures with czech king f8 and
now rook captures an h7 our good friend
the bishop is covering that square so
queen captures on f3 and now bishop the
g7 check and you can't go to e7 because
then the knight falls with check and you
are just in a in a world of pain so king
has to go back to g8 and now we force
this rook to h8 to check we give up the
bishop rook the h7 check king jade and
now we give up the rook as well rook the
h8 to check king captures and now we
capture the knight with check because
the rook also falls so king g7 first
queen g5 uh king to f8 or you know king
to h7 uh a king to h7 is impossible
because the bishop covers this so you
have to go to the back ring king the h8
will get you checkmated after queen to
h6 so this is the this is the only move
now i play queen captures nd8 with
checking g7 queen g5 check and now you
have to repeat because if you go to h8
you just get checkmated so this will be
a force to draw
that's why i said i have to show it
because it's uh
it's just beautiful so here rook to d2
and now bishop to e3 uh this is a
slightly worse than than the line that
we've shown but probably not interested
in uh calculating that uh that crazy
variation so bishop to e3 now attacking
the rook and now rook 2 to d5 you could
also capture on b2 this is probably what
being had in mind captures here attacks
the bishop bishop b4 and uh you know
it's it's still a position that that you
play it's um
it's impossible to make an evaluation
here in in a blitz game so here after
bishop e3 rook 2 to d5 and now we have
rook to g5 attacking the queen queen
captures on f3 and now bishop to e4
attacking the rook and the queen uh
luckily for for prague for uh prague
this doesn't uh win back the exchange
because he has rooked the queen to d1
now attacking ding's queen
but queen captures on the one rook
captures and now c6 let's not forget the
ding has a pass pawn already on c6 now
rook to c8 preparing to defend and now
bishop captures an a7 and now we have
this uh well sort of an end game but
there's so much material on the board
where ding has three past pawns on the
queen side so can prague will stop this
uh f6 challenging the rook rook back to
g1 and here rook to d2
putting pressure on the b2 pawn so pawn
to b4 and now knight to e5
we have pawn to b5 and now g6 attacking
the knight here bishop to e3 attacking
the rook and here it's just very very
hard to find a good move move for prague
if rook to b2 for example going after
the pawn we can just play bishop d5
check if he went to a2 then we would
even pick up the rook so let's say king
h8 we play a4 we continue pushing pawns
it's very very hard to hold this so he
tries king to h8 instead
bishop capture sunday to g captures on
f5 and now bishop to d5
uh we have bishop to d6 now threatening
all sorts of nasty discoveries uh f4
attacking the knight blocking this
diagonal we have knight to d3 and now
pawn to b6 and now of course uh you can
uh see even without calculating that
this is winning for white uh knight
captures on f4 again threatening nasty
discoveries but here thing just captures
bishop captures bishop captures with
check king to h1 and now ponte h5 there
isn't uh really a good move here we have
a4 king to h7 and now pawn to a5 with
bishop back to d2 attacking the a5 pawn
pawn to a6 with bishop to e3 now
attacking the rook and the pawn here but
just rook to b1 defending both uh rook
to d8 attacking the bishop but here just
a7 and he was in this position animal 49
that pragernanda resigned the game and
as this is the second match of the blitz
at the second game of the blitz tie
breaks he also resigns the match
so incredible incredible game it was
just it was just a privilege to watch
today's match every game was such a
thriller so i will i will show um at
least at least one tomorrow maybe even
two but that uh
crazy crazy game where we had a queen
against three pieces is definitely a
must show so we're gonna show that one
uh but yeah remarkable play by both of
them ding i mean of course everyone
expects dink to perform on such a level
he's a 2800 classical grand master uh
but in incredible for for prague who who
got all the way to the finals eliminated
anish geary in the semi-finals and then
uh you know really gave ding a run for
his money and it all came down to blitz
tie breaks and that can go pretty much
uh pretty much either way so yeah really
impressive stuff by both of them and
congratulations to them for for creating
such beautiful games for us to enjoy uh
and really hope you guys enjoyed this
short coverage of this uh event uh so
yeah like i said we're gonna cover at
least one more game perhaps more here of
course you resign you have three
connected past pawns just marching
forward there's nothing to play if the
bishop is captured you bring a queen
into the game and more queens are are
you know uh
soon to follow uh so yeah that's the
game i really hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to salvatore canoe and i would like to
thank mark manor ball swing.cat first
elden
lord and nagarjuna ponogoti for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day